washington journal continues
neil irwin is here to talk to us about
are you spending more or less or the
same he is an economics reporter for the
washington post
and this week separate reports from the
commerce department and the university
of michigan show
increasing an increase in spending
especially when it comes to
retail and restaurant sales so tell us
about
some of the specific areas where the
increase is happening
and why uh the commerce department and
the university of michigan
um believe that this is or or are they
saying that this is an indicator
that uh the economy is getting better
well what we've seen uh
the last few months this isn't just a
one month trend is
a lot of measures the consumer are
looking better so as you say retail
sales
up strongly in in september is the most
recent month we have data for
uh restaurants some of that's gas prices
are up so part of it you know you spend
more at the gas pump so that shows up as
higher retail sales but even when you
exclude gas
it's still retail sales are up these
consumer conference measures they're up
to some of their highest levels since
the
the depths of the recession in 2008
2009. that's a sign that the people are
more
comfortable they're feeling like you
know we're i'm more optimistic about
the days ahead part of that's driven by
the housing market the housing market is
uh
is starting to improve uh we had a
really good housing starts and housing
permits number
for september uh that's a sign that it's
slow it's halting it's uneven but there
is some progress on at least the
consumer
side of the economy the business side
not so good but consumers seem to be
coming back
you wrote on october 17th the headline
september's housing figures may be a
sign of a recovery the census bureau
said that housing starts rose a
remarkable 15 percent in september
to their highest rate since july 2008
analysts had forecasted a 2.7 percent
gain the number of housing permits
also rose at a double-digit rate 11.6
percent
compared with one point one percent uh
forecasters were predicting
is this uh a surprise uh these these
housing numbers or uh
have people sort of been watching this
uh as it's been moving along
well yes and no it was a surprise in the
narrow sense all the analysts all the
forecasters were expecting
numbers not quite so good uh for
september and they turned out to be
pretty good
indeed um what what isn't surprising is
that we're finally getting
a bounce back in housing even though
it's it's early it's not fully
entrenched yet but
it's it's moving the right direction
it's it's hard to overstate how
depressed this housing market has been
for the last four or five years
um you know by any measure of of
construction activity of
of sale prices uh this has been a really
rough time for the housing market it's
been
long it's been uh you know one one
number i've looked at that's it's kind
of interesting if you look at
the percentage of of uh gdp the
percentage of the economy going to
residential investment going to
housing construction uh that has been
lower in this this recession than it had
ever been in the uh
they had to go back to the 1940s lower
than it ever been
less than two percent of gdp um even in
the worst month the worst quarter of the
2000 of the 1981 recession that was a
deep recession
even in its worst quarter it never got
below three percent uh
now we've been below three percent for
something like uh uh
four years in a row so 16 quarters in a
row that's a really depressed housing
market we're starting to claw out of
that depression into something a little
more normal even though we're not there
yet
we're talking with neil irwin of the
washington post we want to find out from
our viewers and listeners
are you spending more or less or the
same based on your feelings
uh about the economy neil irwin has been
writing
about particularly housing figures
showing a sign of recovery and we'll
talk a little bit more about that
we want to find out from our viewers and
listeners are you spending more
less or the same and that's how we've
divided the phone lines for this
particular segment
if you are spending more call us at two
zero two five eight five thirty eight
eighty if you're spending less two zero
two five
eight five thirty eight eighty one and
if you're spending about the same two
zero two
five eight five thirty eight eighty two
again
more 38.80 less 38.81
spending the same 38.82 you can also
send us messages
via email twitter and on facebook
uh you also wrote an article uh earlier
in october regarding cars and big rigs
and what they say
about the economy you say cars represent
the supply side of the economy and the
big rigs are the ones that
move the cars tell us about the
relationship between cars and big rigs
and and what does that say
what i'm drawing is a distinction
between supply and demand in the economy
and uh so demand is is consumer spending
it's all the stuff that we want and
and that we want to buy it's uh it's
restaurant meals it's
things at the grocery store it's uh cars
it's all the things that
it would be nice to have where we need
to have to to get by
and then the supply is the production
side that's that's corporate spending
it's corporate investment it's jobs it's
working
and one way to look at those is cars and
trucks so the trucking industry that's
what distributes uh
you know goods all over the country uh
the the cars are demand you know when
you uh
it's something that you use and consume
um and and as i kind of alluded to
earlier we're seeing
some pretty different signs from those
two sides of the economy in the long run
they have to converge they have to
move together because one man's spending
is another man's income
it's uh you know they're two sides of
the same coin you have to have
uh vibrant consumer demand to sustain uh
uh
supply which is where people have their
jobs and earn their incomes um what's
happening right now is kind of a divide
it's kind of a bifurcation
so uh consumers i alluded to earlier
retail sales doing good consumer
sentiment consumer spending doing pretty
good
uh on the business side things are not
looking so good so corporate earnings
are
under stress uh i i for that story that
you reference
that you referenced i i actually looked
at a few trucking companies that were
showing some
mixed numbers so things are not so good
on the kind of corporate side corporate
hiring
things are a little better on the
consumer side eventually those will
converge one way or the other though now
what we hope for is that
uh the business side will pick up and
and start hiring more and start uh
producing more goods
and that that will then fuel more demand
and so on it could happen in the reverse
we could get a downturn where
consumers suddenly are not having jobs
they're not having incomes and they cut
back and
convergence happens the other direction
so that's the divide and
the uh the pessimism uh if i can use
that word uh in the business community
about the uh recovery
um indicated by your uh article this
morning
outlook for temp jobs uh indicates a
weak market
yeah so uh what i did is i looked at the
historical relationship between
temporary employment and total
employment in the future so
it's actually a pretty good indicator
it's a 77 correlation it's a pretty good
hint of what's going to happen in the
future as to as to overall employment
and the last few months it's not been
good so temporary employment it was
basically unchanged in august it was
down a couple thousand jobs in september
that's a big change from the first part
of the year we were averaging 21 000 new
temporary jobs a year
uh in the first six months of 2012.
that's now kind of
evened off and even declined a little
bit and uh so that's a hint that
job growth is going to be pretty weak in
the fourth quarter if the historical
relationship holds up
we'll only add about 72 000 jobs a month
in the in the final three months of the
year
that would be quite mediocre that'd be
pretty lousy if that's what happens
neil irwin of the washington post is our
guest talking to us about are you
spending more or less or the same
uh discussing specific areas showing
increases
uh or decreases in consumer spending and
how that plays into the strength of the
economy
our first call comes from anthony in
deerfield beach florida
he is spending more anthony you're on
the washington journal
good morning thank you for uh for
allowing me to call in
uh yes i am spending more uh
not through choice of my own though
because uh
i'm getting less uh they they you know
they tell you about the gas prices
that's fine but
uh you go to a grocery store and your
peanut butter goes up
40 your mustard goes up 25
your vegetables are up i mean everything
is up and we're making less
uh i don't count anymore because now
uh i've expired my unemployment benefits
so now i'm not looking for a job so now
the percentages go down
well you know it's 12 or 13 but no no
it's really seven percent
that's those are my feelings yeah um
so so inflation is interesting you know
higher prices for food higher prices for
uh for gas
it really it cuts into people people
don't like it at all
overall inflation has not been that high
through this last few years uh under two
percent which is what the federal
reserve aims for
it's been more like uh 1.7 percent over
the last year um
you know i have a theory on this which
is that people uh uh when when the
inflation comes in
and things they buy a lot that it it
like gasoline and food
it pinches a little more because you're
reminded of it all the time when
inflation happens in
cars and clothing and things that you
buy less often i feel like it's it's
less
uh in the top of the mind the other
thing is when wages are stagnant people
aren't getting raises
inflation hurts a lot more than when
it's uh when when you're actually
when wages are rising too so what we've
had in the last few years is stagnant
wages
uh even declines in some in some areas
and uh
so stagnant wages and prices rising even
a little bit is
is awfully painful in normal times
inflation means prices rise and wages
rise with them
what's happening now is a real wage
decline meaning real wages wages
adjusted for inflation are coming down a
little bit because
uh what people get paid is stagnant and
prices are rising at about two percent a
year so
it certainly hurts back to the phone
cheryl calling from spencer ohio she
says that she's spending less cheryl why
is that
well i'm spending less on
because of a higher gas and higher food
and higher health insurance and so i
spend less as far as
uh other things that i would like to buy
and i'm in that 47
of the people i guess that are
in the poor category uh and i feel that
i'm in that 47 percent because of obama
and i also feel that uh
you know it takes away our dignity and
our respect
and we have to pay more for these other
things and so i have to spend less on
things that i would like to have
that's uh cheryl and spencer ohio uh
is her sentiment something that could
uh stall the economic recovery
yeah it's it's um we were talking about
inflation earlier and and uh
what what cheryl's describing is
something that's pretty widespread so if
you're
if your wages aren't rising if your uh
you know pay or
whatever kind of income you're living on
is stagnant
and the prices for things you have to
buy a lot if gas and food prices go up
uh you're you're in a tough spot and you
have to squeeze spending on other things
that uh that as you said which you would
like to spend money on
uh you know that's that's what a that's
what a bad economy is
and when uh when we're in this very slow
recovery uh you know we only grew
something like one and a half two
percent
in the in the first half of the year uh
when you're in a slow recovery from a
deep downturn
and coming back uh slower than i think
any of us would like that's uh that's
the kind of story you have and the kind
of thing you grapple with
uh in the wall street journal uh
last week on tuesday the article with
the headline confident consumers
spending more
and we're going to be referring to the
chart that they've got here a snapshot
on u.s
and retail restaurant sales and it shows
that um on a monthly basis
from september to october that auto
and parts dealers were up uh
1.3 percent um in august i mean in
september from august
gas was up uh the uh con assumption or
the
the purchases of gas was up 2.5 uh
restaurant and bars
almost a half a percent uh non-store
internet sales uh up 1.8 percent
building and gardening supplies up 1.1
is that also an indication that uh the
housing market is starting to come back
if people are spending more money on
gardening and building supplies
yeah i think it is housing housing is a
really interesting thing because
uh even though housing construction is a
fairly small percent of gdp it's been a
little over two percent in the last uh
last few years
uh it it it has a much bigger ripple
effect through the economy so part of it
is
what you describe so when people buy a
house they probably buy some furniture
they probably buy some garden supplies
some
you know lawnmower whatever they might
need for their for their new house so it
triggers a lot of other retail spending
across the economy
the other thing about housing is uh it's
intertwined in the financial system so
it's uh it's part of people's household
wealth their sense of confidence
so you can imagine a family that uh
maybe their home price has risen a
little bit in the last couple years
they're no longer underwater on their
mortgage
that can make them more confident and
feel more more willing to spend money on
other things that have nothing to do
with housing so
it's a really important thing in the
economy and that's why you know i think
any story that has this economy really
taking off and starting to get a lot
better
has a housing recovery at its core
neil irwin writes about the u.s economy
and the federal reserve for the
washington post he's
written for the post business section
since the year 2000 and also has covered
technology companies real estate
development and the washington regional
economy
we're going back to the phones we're
going to talk to penny in sallisaw
oklahoma she's spending about the same
go ahead penny
well good morning facts do matter and
i think people forget
or are not taking into account the
basic reason for the financial crunch
that we have been
in and uh another thing that i
think is important because i am a
numbers creature
and i'm wondering how much money public
money went into these
banking companies and i tried to find
out but it's an astronomical
problem trying to do all of that
research
and i don't have all that much time to
do it but i think it
i i think that
it's very important all right well it
i i i spent a lot of time on the same
kinds of issues understanding how much
uh the bank bailouts added up to and uh
how big those interventions were and
it's uh
uh it's absolutely hard to hard to get
your head around and hard to get
accurate numbers and reliable numbers uh
it's certainly in the hundreds of
billions of dollars depending on how you
count how do you count loans as opposed
to
uh you know stock purchases how do you
count uh having a guarantee or a
backstop for a 100 billion dollars but
not
but even if that money was never
actually transferred or never spent so
it's
it's not the case that it's a there's an
easy single number for how big were the
were the bank bailouts but
you know it's look um there's a lot of
research uh most prominently by two
economists named
ken rogoff and carmen reinhardt showing
that economic recoveries or economic
times after financial crises are
different they
they last a long time they are slow
they're hard to claw back from
and that's very much the world we're
living in and it's unfortunate we'd like
to have
you know we'd like to think the u.s is
different and that we might pop out of a
the aftermath of a crisis and and be in
much better shape
but in fact what we're seeing this kind
of slow slow growth
uh uneven halting uh that's pretty par
for the course that's pretty typical
when you come
out of a financial crisis and so that's
that's very much the world we're in and
and
uh it is a good reminder of how we got
into this in the first place which was
a financial crisis back in 2008. uh john
is our next caller calling from decatur
georgia he's spending less john you're
on the washington journal go ahead
hey good morning gentlemen i'm spending
less because i'm making far less
in the transportation industry
probably 30 percent less money in the
last three years that i've made
over the last 15 years i've been in this
business
um just to comment on inflation
i heard a bloomberg economist about a
year ago he spent about a half hour
talking about how the real
inflation rate is over nine percent if
you
consider uh the cost of food and gas and
other items clothes and stuff and he
went down a list of the increase in
price and
uh that's you know it's really hurting a
lot of people out here i think it's not
talked about enough but when it comes to
economic growth another
economist i heard that you guys might
find this interesting a little bit of
history
uh i think's pretty relevant came out of
the recession
in the early 80s in the last quarter of
82
the 36 months it followed we created 9.8
million
jobs that's like almost 300 000 jobs a
month
and a lot of people call that
trickle-down economics i just can't
understand why
we call double the job creation we're
experiencing now
30 years ago trickle-down economics is
kind of
you know you should be
questioned john thanks for your call
neil erwin your thoughts sir so first on
on
on inflation you know there's some
people are really skeptical of the
official inflation numbers and i
understand where their skepticism is
coming from but
um you know on on most look uh gas
prices food prices that all goes into
the
the official numbers it all goes into
less official numbers that private
groups come up with
to capture inflation uh but the fact is
we all buy things other than than food
and gas
uh you know you have to buy clothing you
have to you buy computers you buy a car
you
have a house that you have the
equivalent of paying rent on
um you know these are all things that go
into inflation as well and so to just
take out
uh food and energy the things that are
growing the most and say well those are
up nine percent
so so that's what overall inflation is i
you know that's just that's just
misleading
and and not really true uh that said uh
you know the the broader point that this
was a much stronger recovery in the
early 80s is absolutely true we were
growing
uh in the 82 83 84 time period
recovering from that recession
uh we had several quarters in a row of
five six seven percent growth
now we're now we're in the kind of one
and a half percent range somewhere in
that ballpark
uh that was a much more robust recovery
now i think a lot of economists would
argue the reason is that it was a
different kind of recession we were
recovering from
that was a recession that was sparked by
the federal reserve raising interest
rates a lot to try and fight inflation
you know to fight that double-digit
inflation of the of the late 70s early
80s
and that caused a deep recession caused
unemployment to spike to ten percent
when when paul volcker and the federal
reserve felt like uh
they had conquered inflation and
inflation expectations had come down and
things were
in a better shape on the on the
inflation side they cut rates a lot and
so that left a lot of room for the
economy to rebound and it was quite a
recovery
uh you know i i sure look ronald
reagan's president he surely gets
some of the credit for that period as
well uh but it's
it's you know it's uh interesting
question how much do you know what
causality do you draw what uh who do you
attribute that that strong boom to uh i
think paul volcker gets a
a lot of the credit along with ronald
reagan talk to us about how the
um the fed is working now versus the way
it was working
um when uh mr volcker was the chairman
uh in as far as uh moving the economy
forward
and and getting the kind of response out
of this
recession that they got out of that uh
recession during the reagan
administration
yeah i mean the thing to understand is
that these are these are different times
and
and the federal reserve is fighting
different problems so um
then the problem was inflation we had in
the early 80s uh you know you would have
10 11 12 inflation a year even through
those official statistics that our
caller earlier is skeptical of
um and uh you know that was that was
clearly a deeply
entrenched problem in the economy uh
trying to defeat that was the the
overriding goal of of paul volcker the
chairman at the time and and the fed
um so that's why they hiked rates a lot
they got short-term interest rates up to
20
or so uh trying to slow down the economy
and and establish credibility fighting
inflation
we're in a different moment now you know
the problem now is high unemployment
we're still at around eight percent
uh even all these years after the the
recovery technically began
uh eight percent of unemployment is not
very good inflation
is much less of a problem we're at uh
something like 1.7 over the last year
uh two percent right in a range that the
fed is kind of aiming for
so uh you know the reason the fed has
been doing a lot of stuff to try and
lower interest rates and and pump money
into the economy and get the get growth
going
is because they're they're facing and
trying to deal with a different problem
from what we what we fought back then in
the 1980s
back to the phones richard is calling
from merced california he's spending
more
richard thanks for waiting yeah thank
you
uh i just wanted to say uh
neil the idea that you would come on
here
and try to tell everybody that we're all
feeling so much
better uh and that's why everybody's
spending more
that's ridiculous i mean come on
uh our insurance premiums for health has
gone
up 2500 instead of down like
obama said tell me one thing that is
costing less now
uh that that we're all buying
i mean what we buy every every
other day at the stores food and
groceries
and gas those are the things we buy
every day
and for you to say that it's gone up
1.7 let's look at say the last four
years since obama has been in
in the presidency not just last month
or last year for the last four years
it's got to be it's got to be
unbelievable
i know how much more it cost me to get a
jar of mayonnaise or a
or a dozen eggs or a gallon of milk
leave it there richard look um summer of
2008
gas was four dollars a gallon now it's
four dollars a gallon you know i mean i
i i
you can i know it hurts listen people
are people are unemployed
uh wages are not really growing uh wages
are
declining in a lot of cases uh that
hurts but uh
but you know inflation is not the
problem the problem is real wages are
down the problems people are making less
money uh
you know there's a uh you know in terms
of spending look the consumer confidence
measure is done by private groups
they're surveying people all the time
look you're right they're not back to
boom time levels but they're up a lot
from where they were
uh three or four months ago so there's
clearly something happening where people
are feeling a little better
in aggregate even though things are not
where we want them to be and the economy
is not uh not in terrific shape
uh look it's it's all about levels this
entire presidential campaign has been
it's been tough as an economics writer
to
to see people have these arguments about
about the jobs numbers every month
because it
immediately goes to the partisan lens uh
you know the truth is
uh we have a if you're if you're if you
want to put an optimistic spin on it
we're we're seeing growth we've seen
growth for for three straight years
since the recovery began in the summer
of 2009.
if you want to put a negative spin we're
still eight percent unemployment growth
has been very slow it's been too slow to
get us out of the hole we're in
uh so those are the two sides of the
debate in uh
melbourne uh uh north hollywood i'm
sorry melbourne is our caller
north hollywood is where he's calling
from and uh he's spending about the same
go ahead
yeah how are you doing fine go ahead
yeah you know um
i've been in this country since 1984.
and i never um even filed on
unemployment yet
self-reliant independent are these
people not independent no more
all these people are sitting around and
depending on the government to help them
the government can help some of the
people some of the time
but can never help all the people all
the time you are always gonna have low
unemployment high unemployment you're
gonna have this you're gonna have that
but you know what the problem is this
two-party system
it need to be one party because i know
you guys love competition
but all these competitions create
entries scrambles cutting down families
over what politics
you all our labor um um label are you
all about um
republicans and democrats are you guys
ain't human beings no more
first you are human beings melbourne
what kind of business are you in
i'm not i'm a painter i whenever i need
a job
i go there and i see the office
stripping i approach the people
distantly and let them know can i pay
that for you
whatever you can afford that's the way i
work
i work with the people no one in in
helping the poor
no one in singapore they don't care
about the poor politics
that's politics solid tricks so are you
getting more business these days less
business or about the same
i always get i get in business and i
always taking care of my kids
and yet i'm a poor i'm a poor guy but
i'm contented
all right melbourne in north hollywood
florida neil irwin go ahead
uh it's uh it's a hard economy i'm glad
i'm glad he's able to
scratch out a living even if uh like a
little higher income than he has but
it's uh
it's tough out there next up is uh
nathan in uniondale pennsylvania he's
spending less
go ahead nathan hello hello
um yeah my wife just got laid off here
this
last thursday she was working for a
medical laboratory and uh
spending a whole bunch less inflation's
gone clean out of sight
and i've been listening to you talk
about your
economic serve and man you're out the
lunch
i don't understand how you come up with
your ideas
you know money
isn't worth anything like it used to be
i mean i've got a five dollar gold coin
that was minted in 1914
and gold was twenty dollars and seventy
five cents
then a five dollar gold coin
now that same five dollar gold coin is
worth seven hundred dollars
so you tell me that's not inflation
yeah i do uh but gold you can't eat gold
you can't live in gold you can't drive
gold
gold is a it's an important commodity
and and it's it it's interesting to look
at and understand kind of why gold
prices change
but uh but but rising the price of gold
is not
is not inflation per se i know a lot of
a lot of ron paul fans a lot of montris
would would say that
uh that is the case uh you know it's uh
inflation is a rise in the price of the
goods and services that we buy every day
to to live
uh and and the framework that that i use
and that and that you know most uh
most economists who uh kind of work in
in
bank's government uh business uh that's
not the same as
overall inflation when the price of gold
rises we've got an
uh another article from the post uh from
one of your colleagues uh abba
bhattari hopefully i'm not messing that
up too badly
with the headline retailers rush to
offer holiday bargains
stores hope to reel in shoppers with
early
aggressive sales it seems as though
holiday shopping is starting earlier and
earlier these days every year it moves
one week earlier before thanksgiving
now it's getting closer to halloween is
this
a way for businesses to recoup what they
didn't make
in the previous eight months or are they
trying to you know trying to finish uh
close out the year with a big finish and
and and get customers yeah you know
it's gonna be really interesting to see
what happens this holiday season because
we have that trend i was describing
earlier where consumer confidence is up
and and retail spending is up
but uh but the job market is not really
back and and you have a lot of pressure
on businesses
a lot of cutbacks in the industrial
sector um so the question is is which
story becomes true in this these
these crucial holidays uh selling months
do consumers feeling a little better
do they go to the stores and buy a lot
of stuff and does that uh increase
production in factories and and
uh and on the supply side of the economy
or uh or do they say you know i'm not so
sure about my job as a number of these
callers have been
i'm not i don't have enough income i'm
gonna cut back on what i spend this
holiday season
and uh and so we we head back into this
you know very low growth or even another
recession
uh look the holiday season it's it's a
big chunk of all retail
spending and so that's that's kind of
the acid test for uh for this recovery
over the next couple months
and a lot of people that are going to be
out there doing their holiday shopping
are going to be using credit cards is
that
going up or staying the same or going
down
i mean there's a long-term secular shift
toward more people using credit cards as
opposed to cash or checks
um you know that's that's it's one of
the better real-time indicators of
what's happening with retail sales
uh that's every reason to think that'll
continue the question is
uh however they pay how what's what's
going to be the overall level of
spending and activity in the economy
so the use of credit cards is not
necessarily a an
indicator of consumer confidence it's
just the way that they're going to pay
credit card versus cash and it can be a
useful way because the credit card
companies have data
every day of how many people you know
went to went to a store and and ran
their card
uh so it's a good way for for people who
write about these things to kind of
track what's happening with with the
trends
uh but it's uh you know you still wait
for the kind of final numbers to come in
as
as the big retailers report their
numbers as the as the
government numbers are tabulated back to
the phones edwards calling from spring
hill florida he's spending more
thanks for calling edward hello thank
you for having me in your program i like
it very much
the only thing that i i have to say is
i'm spending more on
everything in my home you know
i'm talking about food and and
and and a lot trick and everything
everything is way
you know way up over it was insurance
okay the only thing that that that i'm
saying is
you know you'll like rodney he's gonna
be
outsourcing just like he's been doing
all that's why he's got the money he got
and everybody else is suffering okay
so wake up america okay that's all i
gotta say
neil irwin uh look you know a lot of
this election is hinged on
on uh what what agenda you think will be
best for the economy
and uh i think it's a it's a it's a
debate that we've seen in the
presidential debates we've seen around a
lot of kitchen tables and
and uh as every individual and their own
family kind of have the same debate
i think there's no question that we all
want to see a better economy and and the
question is what
uh what leader and what agenda is going
to get us there uh
one of the items in this chart that
we've referred to from the wall street
journal regarding
u.s retail and restaurant sales at the
very far end on the right is electronics
and appliances
up four and a half percent uh
from august to september
there was a lot of discussion that when
the uh iphone 5 came out that
it was going to jack up the economy it
was going to
some people were saying it was going to
save the economy it says here that uh
spending's only gone up
uh 4.5 why is that yeah well um
so this has actually happened with big
apple product releases in the past uh it
creates a kind of
uh one-time bump in the numbers uh as
people go out and buy an iphone 5 or
or an ipad or whatever the big release
is um
it's not something that that is create
that creates a long-term
change in the trend line um you can get
one month with an extra few tenths of a
point of of retail sales growth
but whatever you spend on an iphone or
ipad you have to not spend on something
else
so it's not as if it's it's creating new
economic activity out of thin air
what it's doing is kind of shifting
spending from uh that people might spend
on another kind of computer or another
phone or another
you know or a vacation or a restaurant
meal and shifting that spending to uh
to a tech product instead back to the
phones union springs alabama
one is spending about the same go ahead
one you're on the washington journal
hey how you all doing today good um
uh i'm feeling about the same but isn't
it true that um
that the dollar bill is is weaker now
that's the reason why
the economy not picking up faster and
that um
it isn't true that that congress
holds the money in in in washington
and they not they they can hold it or
spend it
as they choose is that true or not so
that those are separate issues
so there's um the strength of the dollar
on on the international currency markets
and how strong the dollar is against
the euro or the yen or the pound uh on
that look it's gone up and down
it's not tremendously changed over the
last uh over the last several years was
actually
uh if you look from before the crisis
we're in the same ballpark i i don't
even remember off the top of my head
whether it's
up a little or down a little against the
you know when obama was inaugurated or
or
summer of 2008 before the crisis got bad
uh you know that hasn't been the
overwhelming shift in
in the economic situation um now there's
a separate issue of you know what is
congress spending or not spending and
what should they spend well it's you
know there's kind of two sides to this
on one hand
the uh the deficit is very large we're
nine percent or so of gdp and deficit
spending
uh over time that will have to come down
there's no way a country can
can spend uh ten percent more than it
than it earns
uh uh than its income indefinitely
uh the thing is right now the markets
are not sending any warning signs that
the deficit has to be cut tomorrow so we
we seem to have some time if the markets
are correct
uh the the the you know interest rates
are near all-time lows
uh the u.s government can go borrow
money more cheaply than any other entity
on earth you know two percent
or so uh that's uh that gives congress
and gives uh gives the government some
leeway to
to chart a course to reduce the deficit
very gradually and carefully in ways
that don't
just uh suck the air out of the economy
uh the question is can they do that and
that's what this whole debate over the
fiscal cliff that you hear about that's
what that's going to be
there's all these things that kick in
january 1 that would reduce the deficit
but if they all happened at once would
you know raise taxes on a lot of people
it would uh cut spending on defense and
a lot of other things
so nobody wants to go over that fiscal
cliff but figuring out what kind of
longer-term path to reduce the deficit
is what the big debate's going to be
after the election
we've got another one of your articles
folks can find it at washingtonpost.com
the
headline was is there good inflation and
in the article you talk
about good inflation bad inflation and
neutral
inflation can you explain what those
three are places yeah one one thing the
number of the callers
today we'll be glad to hear i absolutely
agree that that when it's rises in gas
prices food prices
uh commodities that's bad inflation no
question all that does is it
uh it makes it more expensive for for
people to live especially uh kind of
working-class people who
pay a higher percentage of their income
to buy food and fill up their gas tank
uh there's no question that that when
when gas prices and food prices rise
uh which they have they have risen the
last few years just not as much as
some people are arguing um that that's a
bad thing for the economy
um there's there's a more neutral
inflation so
when uh you know when goods that are
bought less often so when
computers or cars things like that are
when the prices rise on those
uh you know it hurts because obviously
you you know everybody wants to have a
computer you want to have a you need to
have a car
but there's a little more flexibility
for people to to plan that spending so
uh you know if if if cars are more
expensive
and you have to keep your old car for an
extra 20 000 miles
uh that's not the worst thing in the
world unlike unlike food where you have
to go to the grocery store because you
have to eat
uh so so that's not quite as bad and
there's actually you know some
some upside to to inflation on uh on the
housing measures so
uh the labor department does what's
called owner uh owner equivalent rent so
what would it cost to rent your house
essentially
if you own a house you're renting it
from yourself is the way the math works
uh
if that actually starts to rise which it
has been uh it can be a good thing for
the economy because it might trigger
more housing construction it might get
growth
going again in ways that are really
constructive and positive for the
overall economy
so in that sense seeing seeing some
rises in those rental measures
could actually be a good thing for the
economy back to the phones
uh quentin in hayward california is
calling us he's
on our line for those who are spending
less go ahead quentin
hi good morning how are you guys good
uh yeah i'm spending less um you know i
hear a lot of people on these lines
and i'm i'm spending less
oh this guy's talking on tv on
yeah no problem i'm spending less
because you know a lot of people that
gets on this line
they you know i'm i'm almost 50 years
old probably don't sound like it but i'm
always 60 years old
so back in the day we had to live within
our means you know i'm saying if you
you can't afford that expensive whatever
then you have to downsize and get
something that's
prop you know basically the same but
less so you just have to you know
everybody wants once once and needs
needs needs these big things
just calm down take it down a couple
notches and save your money spend less
and you know your money you have more
money you know it's like that it's a
simple it's a simple process
you know neil irwin talk to us about uh
savings he
uh the last caller mentioned a little
bit about savings what does savings do
in in in uh the purse the um
pumping up uh consumer confidence yeah
so savings it's it's
it's funny we think of savings most of
us as an active process you
deposit money in the bank or deposit in
a brokerage account and that's saving
the way economists look at it it's more
of a residual it's more
take whatever you earn take your income
subtract spending whatever's left is
saving so
uh if you know if somebody makes fifty
thousand dollars a year and they spend
forty five thousand dollars a year
that person saved five thousand dollars
wherever whether it's you know in a
checking account or in money in their in
their
in their under their mattress or
wherever it might be that counts as
savings
um now what's what happened and the
caller alluded to this is
uh during the boom years leading up to
the recession in 2007
household debt levels got very high so
people were not only not saving they
were actually
dissaving they were doing the opposite
of saving by taking on debt uh
and uh debt levels rose tremendously for
the 80s 90s 2000s
and that's part of the story of why
we're in this uh this dilemma
the problem is for the economy when
everybody tries to get rid of that debt
and pay down debt and
and hike up saving at the same time it
it
it brings a halt to economic activity
because uh you mentioned this
relationship earlier
one man's spending is another man's
income so when everybody's trying to
save they're not spending
and so if you own a store if you own a a
factory
nobody's buying your products and
suddenly you're cutting jobs and the
entire economy is in a bad spot
that's why what you know normally
happens in a recession is the government
starts borrowing more to pick up that
slack
the federal reserve cuts interest rates
that makes the debt burdens a little
easier
so uh those are the ways we normally
have out of it uh it hasn't been enough
in this
in this situation but uh you know
getting getting
savings rates back to a sustainable
level and and building you know
rebuilding
household balance sheets it's called
paying down debts building up savings
that's going to be a crucial step to to
really getting this economy to take off
sometime
uh down the road we're not we're never
going to have a real strong recovery
until that repair of household balance
sheets has happened people have paid
down debt and picked up their savings
uh jaden miles uh sends us this tweet
and once
uh are saying that this point in time
wage inflation would be good yet that
in all caps is tightly controlled
so yeah so so wage inflation it would be
great if the inflation
we saw was on both sides of the ledger
both on uh consumer goods what you buy
and on wages uh what's happened is
instead the reverse so price has been
rising slowly but they've been rising
for for all the goods that consumer
goods that we buy
at the same time wages have been flat to
even down in some industries
so as people are making less those
higher prices pinch a lot more it really
hurts
it would be great if they were moving
together uh it is true
so i'm not sure this is what uh what uh
what what our
contributor was was thinking about but
it is true that
the fed is going to be more inclined to
to hike rates and kind of try and slow
down growth
if there's broad-based inflation
includes both wages and uh
and prices uh if that gets much above
two percent they'll probably start
raising rates and try and slow down
the economy and prevent inflation from
taking hold and really taking off in a
big way
our next call comes from david in holly
soppel
pennsylvania he's spending about the
same go ahead david you're on the
washington journal
good morning
i have a comment in the question the
comment is uh
if you want to get this economy going
you're going to have to
increase the wages about if you don't
have by if you don't have customers
businesses simply can't stay in business
that's number one
now the question is is when you're
talking about neil
when you're talking about uh uh
are people spending more are you talking
about strictly the amount of money
they're spending
or what they are buying do you
understand what i'm saying yeah uh yeah
this is a distinction that i think a lot
of a lot of these calls
you know people are saying the same
thing but but in different terms uh
is it real spending we're talking about
inflation adjusted or just nominal
the retail sales numbers we talked about
that came out on i think tuesday
uh or maybe monday were those are purely
nominal numbers so they're up but part
of the reason they're up is because gas
prices are higher
so people are spending more on gas and
that's not
so much real improvement in standard of
living that's just uh higher prices and
so people are spending more
that said there was some growth even
when you exclude gas so it's clear that
there is some
some increase in real spending our next
call for neil irwin comes from richard
in stevens point wisconsin
he's spending less go ahead richard yes
i called on
spending less but i feel like i'm
spending more
i'm spending less i'm spending every
direction
i'm looking at i feel like we are
getting lost
in this country because how
can i afford it i'm almost a theme of
everybody else
talking like the last gentleman just
said
but how can we keep going
in this direction without you know the
stock market it seems like big
businesses or whatever
have to have in the stock market instead
of
the people of the united states and
really helping
us yeah i could go on on all different
issues to be honest
but the reality is how do we solve this
to really help all of us not just
businesses or shareholders
yeah this is a valid concern so um you
know it is true that over the last three
years
uh since this recovery began the stock
market's up a lot uh corporate balance
sheets are in
quite good shape so if you look at the
major industrial companies they can go
on the bond market and borrow all the
money they need
uh their stock prices are not quite back
to where they were
at at the peak but they're they're
getting back there uh kind of month by
month
um and and things are much harder for
for ordinary workers
uh real uh so median wages the wages of
the person right in the middle of the
income distribution
uh those have been uh falling for for uh
they're actually down below they're i
think 1997 levels uh when
adjusted for inflation so um you know
there's no question that that
this uh this recovery has happened more
uh more dramatically and more decisively
with
uh kind of on the corporate side of the
ledger than than for ordinary americans
i think you know whoever wins this
election in a couple weeks uh
this is one of the the fundamental
challenges uh they're gonna face in the
next four years which is
uh how to how to try and make sure this
uh this recovery goes beyond large
companies and is something really felt
by by people all over the country
neil irwin of the washington post thank
you very much for being on the program
we're going to take a break and when we
come back among
other things we're going to be talking
to raiola door
she's going to be here to talk to us
about oil production and its importance
in campaign 2012
and then later in the program we'll take
an in-depth look at reverse
mortgages that's later on in the program
here on the washington journal we're
going to take a break and we'll be right
back